>> WE ARE UP AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO ALLOW CRIMINALS INTO OUR
SOCIETY.
>> THIS IDEA OF REDUCING BED
SPACE IS SOMETHING NEW.
IT IS EVEN MORE EXTREME THAN THE
GREEN DEAL.
>> THE BIG PROBLEM IS IT'S
BECOME --
>> SOME HOUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
RISKING A SECOND PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN BY CALLING
FOR THIS ABSURD LAST-MINUTE
POISON PILL.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO END
UP WITH SOMETHING THAT DEALS
WITH THE TENSION BEDS, WITH
BARRIERS, WITH TECHNOLOGY, WITH
THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IS
STILL TECHNICALLY ON THE TABLE.
>> Bret: THE NEGOTIATIONS ARE
CONTINUING RIGHT NOW ON THIS
HOUR UPON CAPITOL HILL, BUT A
NEW WRINKLE ABOUT THE TENSION
BEDS NOT LETTING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION NOT HAVE TOO MANY
OF THEM SO THAT MORE
FAMILIES ARE NOT HELD IN THESE
FACILITIES.
THIS IS WHAT THE HOUSE MAJORITY
LEADER SET ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE.
>> CLEARLY, IF WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE COMMITTING CRIMES,
PUTTING IN DANGER EITHER PEOPLE
OR PROPERTY, THEY OUGHT TO BE
TAKEN OFF THE STREETS AND
FRANKLY INCARCERATED OR HELD.
BUT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BEDS
SUFFICIENT NOT TO DEAL WITH
CRIMINALS, WHICH IS WHAT THE
CASE IS NOW, BUT DEALING WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING, PAYING
TAXES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
>> Bret: SO MUCH FOR THINGS
LOOKING GOOD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING THE
DEMOCRATS DO NOT WANT US TO
DETAIN OR SEND BACK CRIMINAL
ALIENS.
THIS IS A BRAND-NEW DEMAND.
CRAZY.
THE PRESIDENT OBVIOUSLY HEADING
TO EL PASO FOR A BIG EVENT.
ALSO TALKING TO LAURA INGRAHAM
TONIGHT AT 10:00 P.M.
LET'S TALK TO OUR PANEL.
"WASHINGTON POST" COLUMNIST MARK
KUYPER.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE BOYS.
I THOUGHT I COULD GET PAST THE
COLD.
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE GOING AWAY.
SOUNDED LIKE THERE IS PROGRESS
BEING MADE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE MOVING THE
GOAL POST.
DURING THE WHOLE SEQUESTER,
THEIR KEY TALKING POINT IS THEY
ARE FOR ENFORCEMENT, THEY ARE
FOR ALL THE STUFF.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY ARE
THREATENING A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN OVER DETENTION BEDS.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
LOOK, IT'S CLEAR THEY AREN'T
SERIOUS ABOUT COMPROMISE, NOT
SERIOUS ABOUT REACHING A
BIPARTISAN DEAL, THE PROBLEM IS
THE SHUTDOWN ISN'T THE ANSWER
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT AFRAID OF
THE SHUTDOWN BUT NO APPETITE
AMONG AND AMONG THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS, SO TRUMP NEEDS TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT TO SHIFT
THIS DEBATE.
I THINK THE WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
THREATEN A SEQUESTER, NOT A
SHUTDOWN, TO GET THE DEMOCRATS
TO GIVE HIM HIS BORDER MONEY.
IN DECEMBER AT TEN MONTHS FROM
NOW, THE 2011      2011 OBAMA BD
NOW, THE 2011      2011 OBAMA BE
NOW, THE 2011      2011 OBAMA BT
NOW, THE 2011      2011 OBAMA BC
NOW, THE 2011      2011 OBAMA BP
NOW, THE 2011      2011 OBAMA BS
KICKED IN IN 2011.
THAT MEANS IF CONGRESS DOESN'T
ACT AND DOESN'T FIND SOMETHING
WITH THE WALL, $55 BILLION IN
DOMESTIC SPENDING GETS CUT,
WHICH ARE DEMOCRATIC PRIORITIES.
DO DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT TO LOSE
$55 BILLION IN DOMESTIC STANDING
JUST TO DENY DONALD TRUMP
$5.7 BILLION FOR HIS BORDER WALK
WHICH MEANT I DON'T THINK SO.
TRUMP NEEDS TO GET A CONTINUING
RESOLUTION, WHICH DEMOCRATS
CANNOT SAY NO TO, CONTINUE
SPENDING AT THE CURRENT LEVEL
UNTIL THE END OF THE YEAR, THEN
SAY I'M NOT GOING TO DO A DEAL
ON THE SEQUESTER THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE $5.7 MILLION FOR MY
BUDGET WALL.
WE WOULD NOT TO BE CLICHE, BUT I
DEMOCRATS ARE REALLY WILLING TO
DIE ON THIS WALL?
I MEAN, ON THE TENSION BEDS?
>> I WOULD BE MYSTIFIED IF THEY
WERE.
THEY WERE DOING PRETTY WELL.
THEY HAVE THE PRESIDENTS ON THE
ROPES.
HE AGREED ON THEIR TERMS, WAS
NOT GOING TO GET THE
$5.7 BILLION OF THE WALL.
WHEN THE DEBATE IS ABOUT THE
WALL AND THE LAW ONLY, DEMOCRATS
WOULD MAKE.
WHEN THE DEBATE IS ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY, THE PRESIDENT WINS.
I AM MYSTIFIED BY THIS DETENTION
BAD THING THAT I KNOW THEY DO
NOT LIKE THE I.C.E. POLICIES,
BUT I DON'T EVEN THOUGH BY
MINIMIZING THE NUMBER OF BEDS
WOULD CHANGE THOSE POLICIES.
I THINK EITHER THIS IS A
MOMENTARY SNAG BEFORE EVERYTHING
COMES TOGETHER BEFORE THE LAST
MINUTE, LIKE IT DOES IN
CONGRESS, OR WE ARE HEADING FOR
IN OTHER CR.
I THINK YOUR IDEA IS REALLY
SMART.
>> Bret: CONTINUING
RESOLUTION.
>> TO GIVE NEGOTIATORS A LITTLE
BIT MORE TIME OR IF THEY GO
THROUGH THE END OF THE YEAR,
TRUMP IS PLAYING A MUCH LONGER
AGAIN.
>> Bret: AT THE SAME TIME YOU
HAVE ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
OTHERS SAYING I.C.E. SHOULDN'T
BE FUNDED AS WELL.
THE BACKTRACK OF THIS
NEGOTIATION ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE?
>> IT'S ALSO IN EXTREMELY BAD
FAITH.
THE REASON WHY THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH DETENTION BEDS IS BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE REJECTING IT.
LET'S LOOK AT WHY WE GOT HERE.
LAST YEAR, THERE WERE NUMBERS OF
REPORTS SHOWING THE HUMANITARIAN
SITUATION INSIDE THESE DETENTION
CENTERS WAS NOT GOOD.
OVERCROWDING, SO THE WHITE HOUSE
SENT A LETTER TO CAPITOL HILL
DURING THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN
IN JANUARY AND OFFERED
$5 BILLION, ALMOST AS MUCH AS
THE WALL, TO FUND 52,000 I.C.E.
DETENTION BEDS TO EXPAND THE
HUMANITARIAN SITUATION THERE TO
MAKE SURE AND MORE PEOPLE WERE
HELD HUMANELY.
NOW HERE WE ARE WITH DEMOCRATS
AT THE LAST MINUTE SAYING WE ARE
GOING TO PUT A CAP ON THE NUMBER
OF HUMANITARIAN BEDS THAT YOU
CAN HAVE AND, BY THE WAY, THAT
MEANS YOU CAN RELEASE CRIMINAL
ALIENS AND ILLEGAL ALIENS INTO
SOCIETY.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE
HERE.
AS
WE ARE FOR BORDER SECURITY, NOT
FOR OPEN BORDERS, YET PROVING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POINT BY
SAYING THERE IS AN OVERCROWDING
CRISIS AT THE BORDER AND AT THE
SAME TIME THEY ARE ADMITTING
THAT, LOOK, WE HAVE A PROBLEM
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY WAY TO
DEAL WITH IT OTHER THAN JUST
LIMITING -- ONE MORE THING, WE
HAVE DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AREN'T --
THOSE IMMIGRANTS ARE HERE
WORKING AND LAW-ABIDING PAYING
THEIR TAXES AND SHOULD BE HELD
AT ALL.
THAT IS THE DEFINITION OF OPEN
BORDERS WHEN YOU DO NOT WANT
THEM TO BE HELD FOR COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY WITHOUT PERMISSION,
WHICH IS A FEDERAL CRIME.
>> Bret: AT THE SAME TIME, THE
NINTH CIRCUIT OF APPEALS HAVE
RULED THE HUMAN
ADMINISTRATION CAN CONTINUE
BUILDING THE WALL.
AND TAKE A LISTEN TO    TO THE C
AND TAKE A LISTEN TO    TO THE I
AND TAKE A LISTEN TO    TO THE F
OF STAFF.
>> IT'S NOT A PRECEDENT.
THIS IS THE LAW.
I THINK WE'VE HAD 58 DECLARATION
OF NATIONAL EMERGENCIES SINCE
THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY ACT WAS
PASSED IN 1970s.
HE WOULD PREFER LEGISLATION AND
IT'S THE PROPER WAY TO SPEND
MONEY IN THIS COUNTRY PAID BUT
IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN, THE
PRESIDENT PROCEEDS WITH HIS
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY, NATIONAL
SECURITY, HE WILL LOOK AT THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES ACT AS A
WAY TO DO HIS JOB.
>> Bret: HE COULD MAKE IT DOWN
THAT ROAD TONIGHT IN EL PASO.
>> I THINK THAT WOULD BE A BIG
MISTAKE BECAUSE, FIRST OF ALL,
HIS OWN PARTY WILL REBEL AGAINST
THAT BECAUSE
'S THEY THEY ARE WORRIED THAT
THE ALEXANDRA CUSTER CORTEZ WING
WOULD USE THIS FOR A GREEN NEW
DEAL.
THE WAY TO GO IS TO CONTINUE
THIS RESOLUTION.
THINK ABOUT WHAT A CONTINUING
RESOLUTION DOES.
IT'S A DEFEAT FOR DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI NOW HAS TO
ABIDE BY THE PAUL RYAN SPENDING
LEVELS FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR, SO
THEY JUST WON THE MAJORITY
CEDING THE POWER OF THE
PROSPECTIVE REPUBLICANS.
IT GIVES TRUMP $1.3 BILLION
TOWARDS HIS BORDER WELCOMING THE
GOAL OF ANY WILL FIND HIM OTHER
FUNDS IN THE CAN START BUILDING
IT NOW FOR IN DECEMBER, HE GETS
THE LEVERAGE BECAUSE THEY GET
$51.5 BILLION IN SPENDING THEY
WANT AND THEY'LL CAVE BECAUSE
THERE IS NO SHUTDOWN.
IT'S AN AUTOMATIC SPENDING CUT.
>> Bret: STENY HOYER SAYS
TODAY THEY DO NOT WANT TO DO A
CR.
>> WELCOME WHAT ARE THEY GOING
TO DO?
>> Bret: AND OTHER GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN?
>> NO.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER TRY THAT LAST
YEAR AND CAVED IN THREE DAYS.
>> THEY WANT REPUBLICANS TO SHUT
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT FOR THEY DO
NOT WANT TO BE BLAMED ON THE
SHUTDOWN.
>> THE THE ECONOMY ACTUALLYD
WELL, THERE WASN'T AS
DIRE STRAITS OF EVERYONE WAS
CLAIMING THAT THEY ARE --
BE WHEN I MEAN, UNLESS YOU
WEREN'T GETTING A CHECK.
>> ALL THOSE PEOPLE GOT BACK PAY
RECENTLY AND THAT'S DIFFERENT
FROM PEOPLE IN THE MIDWEST WHO
LOST THEIR JOBS IN THE FINANCIAL
COLLAPSE AND DIDN'T GET A JOB.
IT WAS OVERBLOWN BY A LARGE
PORTION WHEN IT CAME TO THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
POLLING AND THE DATA, THE
ECONOMIC DATA BEHIND IT.
>> Bret: DOES THE BAD THING GO
AWAY?
DO THEY FIGURE THIS OUT?
>> THEY HAVE TO BACK OFF OF
THIS.
OR HE'S GOING TO TAKE THE
SMARTER APPROACH.
>> I AGREE.